So let's dive in and create our new project.
Now to do this, we're going to be using our Epic launcher.
We need to make sure that we have our engine version installed, which in this case we're
going to be installing 5.3.
From there, you will have a launch button.
This will launch a separate window.
And inside of this window, we can open up recent projects or create projects based off
of various templates.
Now for our project, we're going to be using the automotive product design and manufacturing
templates and we're going to use the blank to start with.
We'll cover here in just a little bit about what these templates do, but just know that
this is going to serve as our starting point.
Next we'll want to set our project location.
So this is where your project files will be stored.
And then we'll also give our project a name.
Now it's important on both of these, both on your project location and your project
name that you keep those file paths short.
Ideally, you should keep these well with under 20 characters.
The shorter the better.
To explain in a short, very quick, concise summary, the engine, in particular when working
with operating systems like Windows, there is a character limit of 255 characters, which
can quickly be overtaken with several different files that ship with the engine.
So in short, just keep your file path short.
Keep your project name as short as possible and then click create.
So let's go ahead and just step through that process real fast.
So here I have our launcher and you can see that I have 5.3.2 installed.
I'll click launch.
And we'll give it a second to pop open the window.
All right.
So after about 30 seconds of the engine installing everything that it needed to, you can see
that we now have our Unreal projects browser window.
So I'm going to select the automotive product design and manufacturing section.
And you can see here we have that blank project.
So all I need to do is go ahead and put in my project location and give my project a
name and then hit create.
That will go ahead and create our project.
To better understand what templates are, it's important to understand that templates aren't
actually using a special version of the engine or opening special things that you don't otherwise
have with the engine.
In fact, every template that ships with the engine utilizes the exact same underlying
core engine.
The difference is when we use any of these automotive templates, they will often preset
certain values or enable certain plugins that that project or that template was designed
to use.
So in the case of our automotive project, there are a few things that turn on, for example,
such as our sudden position calculator plugin, the data Smith importer we even have.
And you can see here's a couple of settings in the project.
Our reflection capture resolution has been bumped up to 2048 and our default RHI has
been changed to DirectX 12.
Every single one of these settings, every single one of the plugins that is utilized
by those templates, you absolutely can go in, enable yourself, change those settings
beforehand, change them after.
Again, it's important to understand that the template is just pre-setting these things
for you so you have a good starting point, but you absolutely can modify them.
And that's the lead point thereafter.